what we have you look at now is a whole
bunch of different things to do with
lines when they interact with each other
okay so under tell you I'd like you to
write the following sentence with it
okay when we have parallel lines now
this is the beginning of a sentence will
finish it in a minute but just before we
go on and finish the sentence I just
want to pause and say parallel what do
some just parallel me yeah Abby what
would you suggest to laze it never be
okay now this is an interesting giant
asked you guys to all put your pens and
pencils down and we've got for a minute
I'll show you something a bit
interesting because this is one time
definition that's really helpful but
it's not the only one I'll show you why
ok so how look at this pair of lines
that i have here okay i'm just picturing
these and they imagine a dog forever now
i think we all agree if these lines went
on like up through the ceiling and down
through the floor they never meet do you
agree with that like I mean roughly okay
so we've got a parallel and you all
right with that okay now watch this once
you look at my pair of lines now okay if
they went on forever like this one going
out the window and this one going out
the door would they ever meet they still
wouldn't meet with them what do we call
these parallel not so much so this is a
good start why's that lemony that's a
good start but we need a little more can
we add more on to our definition to be
more Javier like that point in the same
direction and everything ok so I'm going
to take both of those this is um Stein
madhavi's that they don't intersect they
never collide right but they go in the
same direction that's the critical thing
these guys are going to meet but they're
not going in the same direction right
that makes it so that's the picture yes
there's one like that these are called
skew lines lines like ice cube up like
yeah so they are not parallel but they
still never need okay that's okay i
think its batteries night but overcharge
you later Horace Austin okay correct
yeah so if I started a fishing w so if I
pointed them back out at you guys as
long as they are as christian said
pointing in the same direction so i
don't mean to point out any one but it's
long as they're pointing that way my
train tracks is a nice way to think
about train tracks they never kill each
other at least you hope they don't cuz
that's gonna be a problem for the train
at that point so they're always doing
this in Griffin think so well we have
these lines that are parallel there are
lots of interesting patterns now we're
going to look at a few of them over the
space of this week the first one is a
pattern called corresponding eggs i'm
going to show you what that looks like
so with your ruler there i would like
you to draw a pair of parallel lines now
I in fact have my rule and that's why
I've got this up at the moment I know
it's a little bit faint but I hope you
can see it can you see my ruler there
can you make it out okay so with your
roller there I would like you to draw a
pair of parallel lives now there's a lot
of different ways to do this but we're
just going to do a quick and easy way
today which is can you see my ruler has
two sides on it right I want your
paternal there make sure it doesn't move
use one side to draw a line like this
and then keeping your ruler in the same
spot so it doesn't move so they're
facing in the same direction draw a line
on the other side on the opposite side
of your ruler can you do that for me
okay so so long as you've got two lines
facing in the same direction it's okay
all right let's important and in fact if
you want a little differently to the
person see
that will be great the important thing
is that they're parallel yours my friend
straight across or up and down parallels
the important bit okay right now before
we go any further I want to know how we
started this sub topic and we label
things so when you talk about them let's
give these lives these intervals let's
give them some names okay so i'm going
to call this first 1a b so that's what
that line name is it goes from A to B
and I'm gonna call this one c d can you
guys make that out can you read it yeah
okay so that's good I've got a pair of
lines now I've got them as parallel so
to indicate they're parallel but they go
on the same direction I'm going to label
them in this way I put some little
arrows on them like this hands up if
you've seen these before he's familiar
yeah it's not listen if you think he
turns down so what this indicates is
they're going in the same direction
they're parallel now again with your
ruler I want you to move it so that it's
offered and differing or it's not
parallel to those two and you can make
it any angle that you like so long as
it's going to cut both lines that's the
important thing yes uh no no it's okay
the picture is what I what you have okay
so I only draw a new line I'm going to
draw worry about there and I don't need
my ruler anymore as you can see the
important thing is it cuts across both
lines now that phrase is really
important that it cuts across both lines
that's where this line gets its own
special name it's got a name that I'm
going to spell for you here
this light is called a transversal
transversal literally means it goes
across right so I'm you might say oh I'm
traversing the taranta means I'm going
across a large area so transverse or the
line that cuts across these are the two
parallel lines okay so if you could
label it with me that'd be great so that
you know how to describe this thing so
I've a B and C D they're parallel I've
got this guy here oh you need the name
doesn't here let's give him a name okay
so you can see I've got a whole bunch of
different points that have been created
right I've got the start in the end up
there and down here and then I have
these ones in the middle so I want to
name all of them okay so i'm going to
call these P Q R and s okay so yes PS
slide from the top and coming out here
that's my transversal a B and C D are my
parallel lines okay now I want your
carefully your diagram right I want you
to look in particular at these angles
I'm going to mark in right now she's a
different color have a look at this
angle here what's its name have a look
at my what's that called has a name
right Christian what would you call know
anyone ya Miriam have a look how do we
name angles again we use three letters
right what three letters do we use data
yeah yeah yeah okay so we start along an
arm like here you go all the way up to
the what's that cause it starts with a V
the point in the middle of the angle of
that call the vertex very good so we
started on arm we're going into the
vertex and then we go along the other
arm so this angle we can call it a cube
p I'm gonna label that down the bottom
here angle a cue p okay all right now I
want you to look really carefully at
your diagram do you lose
that angle angle a QP is exactly the
same size and if you like you can borrow
a protractor to test it out it's exactly
the same size as this guy do you see
this one in young what's the name of the
same what would you call it there's a
whole bunch of different names that will
work Adam um um c RQ c ah q that's
perfect that's that names that goes
along the arms and it goes the vertex in
the middle so I'm going to market whoops
it's than what i wanted to do with yes
yep there's a whole bunch of different
aims that i could use that would
describe the same name because I've got
lots of points that can work okay but I
think able see a queue is nice so you
can see just by looking at and i'll even
zoom in for you and I'd like you to look
at your diagram as well how to look at
yours do you see you should have a pair
that looks just like that and they kind
of go off at an angle like this yes yeah
very good so what we're looking at here
is pair of angles because they're facing
in the same direction they kind of match
up to each other okay so let's conclude
this down the bottom right angle a QP
and angle C R cube now look a little bit
different on your diagram but they
should still be corresponding matching
like this i'm going to say they are
corresponding angles
now not only are they corresponding
matching to each other but I want you
look really carefully how big they are
look at the size of the angles right
what can you tell me I'll zoom in again
what key talking about the size of the
two angles what do you say they are
exactly the same in fact I'm even going
to get a tiny projector on a really
really big diagram and on mine that
looks like my protectors upside down
that's 50 degrees exactly and you can
even see if I slide at a wall you're
going to end up with the same size a and
in fact what I'd like to do I'll pass
these out a minute I wish you'd have a
look at your angels to go any different
size but the important thing is they're
the same size as the corresponding pairs
okay so there's a pair of corresponding
angles and these angles are the same
size
so the way we write this being that just
like we had before we describe the able
sighs I say oh it's equal something well
these are equal to each other so I'm
going to say therefore that's what my
three dots means therefore angle a QP is
equal to in size it's equal to and go
see our cue okay they're equal to each
other I'll zoom back out so you can see
the whole picture now okay now I've just
identified one pair of corresponding
angles but you should be able to see
it's actually a whole bunch of pairs of
corresponding angles do you notice that
right could someone for example name
just name any other angle on the diagram
any angle at gone yeah Aiden I'm dr cute
Oh slow down you're too quick for me
okay I'm drq where's d RQ so that's uh
that's this guy here isn't it it's all
right yeah and which one does it
correspond to be yeah this guy up here
right in fact it's a whole bunch of
pairs I was like you we've just gone two
pairs right I'd like you to write down
every pair of corresponding angles you
can see in this way you can see how I've
said that they're equal to each other
and I'm even going to write because they
are corresponding angles
it's nice that we can show it by
measuring but you don't need to measure
because they corresponding they have to
be exactly equal to each other okay